AST 100VISAREACH  T COUNTRYESHD
ILLISG THE FROM TAIM LACK S
WHYD.PP WELL, T T GOIY
ACCORDING TO SVOCO JOURNALISTSHH
CTED TO BE AIGTCH,HINIGHT
INNDOWN R ST
ARE NOT UNCOMMON AFTE
S MATC ONE DECFIRE
INTDSLEPITC TEAGAS IS NOT
CHILDREN.AGAINTO THEPP SNDE  FAL
ONE EXIT AS KLAS POSSIBLE,OPLE G
OUBEEN KILLED MOST INSTANT THE T
INJURIESPITALS WITH VARIOU
LOOF T PEVEN
BEHEY ARD  DIED TLNUTE.
OW IT ORRIFIC
A DISTANCE.GI IP
YOUR KIDS, OR SEOLOTH Y A
E CAUSE YOU
DN'TREATHEAVNEANIES VOO OKIS.
EVALUATIONO W WILL BE OROUGH
SOLD IN ANRCAPACITY TYPE O.
APPARENTLY, ACCORDING TO THE
TD.HOULD  BIN30,000 SELALSOIDEN
OESN'T WANT TO LETNOTHEREN IN TE
LOT OF SOULSEARCHING TO DO
W
TEININES IN
HIORTHSENDADSTER.E E WE S
HEALRS,
CL
G KEE HAVING
RAPPLE WH S WHTCH, IS
O BE FNDE OLY .
WELEY.
T.
AS WE MENTD TH
T THINCIDEO
APRIL 1989MIL
FT,
HILLSBOSTULTIMATELY, WING
N A SOCCER
DE WIT
RIS ATS.
IT WAS O ORIST.
ANIN THE96